So you might remember the birther movement,
which claimed that Barack Obama was not actually
eligible to be president because of some combination
of he was born in Kenya or he was Indonesian
or his dad was an American.
Or he once a dog meat in Indonesia.
Know?
Well, whatever the explanation was, it was
a ridiculous idea.
Barack Obama was born in Hawaii, but it was
a hugely racially tinged movement, which actually
Donald Trump was at the front and center of.
Trump was one of the loudest and most prominent
birthers for a period of months, if not more
than a year, talking about Barack Obama's
birth certificate and the entire thing.
Now, within mere hours of Kamala Harris becoming
Joe Biden's running mate, the birthers are
instantly back.
It's almost like if you're not white, they
question whether you're really an American.
That seems to be the underlying theme here.
Suddenly, suddenly being put forward.
Now, I on the one hand, I don't want to give
this too much oxygen, but I do want to lay
it out generally for you.
A guy named John Eastman tweeted, quote, Is
Kamala Harris eligible for the office of vice
president?
Here is my article published by Newsweek exploring
the issues.
Short answer, it depends.
Now, why Newsweek even published this at all
is a good question.
Eastman teaches law at Chapman University
and is a fellow at the Claremont Institute.
If you research the Claremont Institute, you'll
find that there are right wing think tank
that was supported very early of Donald Trump
and has stuck to Trump and Trump ism.
Like, I don't know, super glue, whatever metaphor
you want to use.
Um, no, of course.
Kamala Harris was born in Oakland, California.
What possible argument would there be that
she's not eligible to be the president or
vice president?
Now, remember, in order to be vice president,
you have to be constitutionally eligible to
be president.
So that's why it's relevant.
The argument is, I hope you're ready for this.
Harris's dad is Jamaican and was not an American
citizen when Kamala Harris was born in I believe
it's 1964.
Kamala Harris, his mom is from India and she
was not a U.S. citizen at the time that Kamala
Harris was born in Oakland, California.
Thus, Kamala is not a natural born citizen
and thus could not be vice president because
she is ineligible to be president of the United
States.
Now, in the article, Eastman goes really into
the weeds with arguments about the 14th Amendment
and the definition.
Again, I mean, it's like Barack Obama.
Number two, the arguments about what does
it mean to be natural born?
It's Obama birther ism redux.
And and by the way, they are only pushing
it further by saying this isn't only the law
today.
It's about what the founders meant when they
established how citizenship is conferred.
And we can't just look at court decisions
today, although they have some court decisions
they claim suggests Khamal is not eligible.
It's also about interpreting the desires of
what the founders meant hundreds of years
ago.
Now, there is a lot more to this.
There is actually a real law conversation
that could be had, but in practice, it's only
being applied to Barack Obama and now to Kamala
Harris.
In practice, this is the same racist birther
ism that we saw with Barack Obama.
And my instinct is and I hope that this is
the case.
I don't think it's going to get a lot of pickup.
And part of the reason why isn't going to
be because it's completely baseless factually,
which it is completely baseless factually.
With Obama.
It was about the president, with Kamala Harris.
It's about the V.P..
And I think that may keep it from getting
the attention it otherwise might.
And, of course, you know, no one said this
about John McCain born in Panama.
They're just fine accepting.
Well, it was a military base and thus it's
fine.
Nobody said this about Ted Cruz when he was
a candidate for the Republican nomination
in 2016, even though he was born in Canada.
As you may or may not know, current British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson was an American
citizen because he was born, I believe it
was in Manhattan, although he has since renounced
it.
That's no problem.
But is Kamala Harris, born in Oakland, eligible
to be vice president?
All of a sudden now they have questions.
It's the same dog whistle stuff and it's almost
it's too predictable.
It's too on the nose that this is the direction
immediately.
You have some pro Trump think tank legal scholar
talking about let's sort of hope that this
is it.
But I did want to let you know that it was
going on.